this is a regular occurrence in South
Africa
to protect the Rhinos on his land Derek
leverton says he has no choice but to
trim their horns
it's uncomfortable to watch but it's
become a necessity
a trimmed horn makes the animal less
valuable to poachers look I don't like
trimming holes I literally don't like it
this is the alternative a calf left
orphaned after its mother was poached
her horn gouged from her body
this is the dumbest most unnecessary
Extinction in the history of human
intervention and Wildlife
the world's rhinos are in South Africa
and about three quarters of them are on
private property
[Music]
the rhinos are tracked by helicopter and
immobilized using a tranquilizer dart a
blindfold and earplugs are used to
reduce external stimuli but vets say the
procedure itself is painless
at the correct level there is actually a
protective layer still over the bed and
there's no feeling it doesn't the animal
doesn't even feel the wound has been
removed to be honest
rhinos use their horns to defend
themselves to find food even to play but
to poachers this represents wealth it's
known as gray gold and retailers will
pay up to 100
000 US dollars a kilo
Vietnam and China are considered the two
largest markets horns are used in
traditional medicine for hangovers to
reduce fever even cure cancer although
there is no scientific evidence to
support these claims the demand has
decimated the populations of black and
white rhinos the government says 259
were killed in the first six months of
this year if we are just doing the same
over and over again and don't try a
different approach we will never be
successful and we will see rhinos
extinct while we are all on this planet
previously trimmed right some
conservationists say the solution is to
legalize the export of horns
internationally so we could literally
swamp the market with horn tomorrow
destroy the business of poaching
save the animals and and we could do so
with a product that we're already
trimming painlessly and it grows back
you can shave a sheep and sell the wool
where do you draw the line
researcher dang fun Nam has studied
consumer habits in Vietnam we don't know
whether the supply of rhino hunt in a
legal Market would be enough to meet
demand from consumers in a legal trip
trimmed horns are marked microchipped
and stored in registered stockpiles
Reserve owners estimate there are
currently 20 tons in storage
we can send seven times more horn to the
Asian markets than the poaching
syndicates are managing by slaughtering
the animals and if we do it our way no
animal ever gets hurt again there are
concerns we asked the environment
Minister if the government would
consider legalizing the trade not at
this stage she says a ministerial panel
looked into this issue two years ago
and the high level panel reaffirmed the
decision that was taken by the South
African cabinet in 2016 that the
conditions are not right at this stage
to to legalize the trade those on the
ground disagree nothing what we are
doing is working so we must change
something and that's the only thing that
hasn't been tried so we must openly
discuss it
best case scenario there are 15 000
rhinos left in South Africa and Industry
insiders believe they could be wiped out
in just six years we know they can be
saved
if you know how to and you
don't do it but you wait for everybody
else too
then it's
your fault
Emily anguin Al Jazeera greater Kruger
region South Africa